a fourth term for victor orban who likes
to think of himself as the strong man of
europe his supporters are elated
whatever the overall thinking hungary's
voters have given their leader an
overwhelming vote of confidence
we look pretty good we've never looked
as good as tonight we won a huge victory
it can even be seen from the moon but in
brussels for sure
that last quip was aimed at the eu all
ban is its biggest critic from within
for the leader of the opposition peter
marquis zai who had brought together six
parties in a united alliance it was a
humiliating loss in his hometown
and an overall defeat for his alliance
there is no democracy in hungary there's
no free and fair elections regardless of
the results
only weeks ago opinion polls showed
marquis zai's opposition gaining support
the war in ukraine and orban's close
relationship with russia's president
vladimir putin appeared to be negative
factors
but all band told voters they were safe
with him he wouldn't get involved in the
war
nato and the eu may be giving military
support but there will be none from
hungary
and so the ornate national assembly
building in budapest remains dominated
by orban it stands as a symbol of
defiance to the liberal policies of the
eu
and of all bans cooperation with russia
and china
for the european union i think this will
be a very heavy dilemma because if that
will be a landslide victory and
apparently it will be a landslide
victory the question uh maybe posed
whether the existence of
semi-authoritarian member states in the
european union is really just a
temporary challenge
or that will be the new business as
usual
on monday a european team of observers
will announce whether they view the
election as free and fair
in the 2018 poll they declared it wasn't
fair and that may well be the verdict
this time
opposition parties will have been
telling them their problems have
included limited access to the media and
government-induced bias by the vast
majority of news outlets
and so what caused this apparent
turnaround in orban's position it could
be a number of factors inaccurate
opinion polls orban claiming that the
opposition wanted hungary to join the
war in ukraine
and perhaps more than any of the others
the fact that so many people wanted a
trusted strong leader at a time of
crisis
andrew simmons al-jazeera budapest